i've just never seen like i
even as a kid like you said like yeah
the brat was crazy funkified and little
kim was
was that [ __ ] and lauryn hill and the
fuji's but
now it's just like there's just so much
energy
that i feel like we've never at least
i've never witnessed
as far as just like the totality of like
the industry respecting female artists
because it used to be like yeah you're
dope but you're like dope for a girl
who are you telling i was in that no i
know you had to take a lot of those
punches i had to take those [ __ ]
punches bro like
when i was when i was starting to rap i
literally got told by one of my peers
like
let's be honest you know are you really
because we were all selling cds like we
i would sell cds on the street you feel
me like
[ __ ] hard sales right and uh we we
all finished selling cds out on the
street or whatever and then we we went
and sat down and we're eating and he's
like you know
telling me about why you know he'll be
the one to pop off out of
all of us because let's be honest no
females are really ever gonna pop off
like that and i just
sat there and i and now you know that i
my career has gone for
working at subway yeah no but um
i did have to remind him of like bro
honestly that affected me like that
[ __ ] with my head for years because i
was just like
like do i give up on this [ __ ] like
there is only one spot like
you know why would a mexican girl be the
one to [ __ ] do this you know like it
doesn't matter that you're dope like
people will probably not care you know
and i'm glad i
kept going but um i'm so happy for where
music is right now you know i'm
happy that independent artists can draw
music however the [ __ ] they want that
there is more respect for
fast rappers because even that as well
for a long time if you rap fast
you're you'll never have a hit record
and now it's like you hear
jack harlow or you hear anybody who's
rapping a little bit faster and you're
like okay bet
like there is that or now there's female
rappers and now there's more mexicans
and
latinos one of the biggest [ __ ]
genres like that's the biggest
all these things are a culmination or
like lgbt
community is now so much more accepted
and like people are literally looking
for
lgbt representation so to me it's like
it's crazy that all these things that
for
years held me back and that are so
authentically me
are now accepted you can only
imagine how happy i am that this is the
case because this is what i wanted you
know i mean other than that i'm like
i'm good i'm not starving i'm living
pretty good